the Grenville tower fire on the 14th of
June 2017 that killed 71 people spread
up the outside of a block of flats that
had been wrapped in plastic that burns
how and why it was put there is the
focus of a police investigation and a
public inquiry
but Sky News has identified the disaster
is a symptom of a much wider problem a
national fire safety crisis as
increasing amounts of combustible
plastic materials have been used on
buildings of all sizes we've had a push
to insulate buildings and you know the
easiest way to cheapest way to insulate
them is using these combustible
materials and some we lost uh it was off
the ball as the plastics industry
capitalized on the green agenda the
building regulations failed I'm afraid
there will be buildings that are that
aren't safe and and that must be a worry
for the people who are falling asleep in
them the danger from combustible
plastics has grown as successive
governments ignored repeated warnings to
take action do you know for certain that
your submission containing warnings
wasn't the only submission containing
warning yes I've seen other people
submissions and crucially fire safety
experts who tried to warn about the
dangers were routinely silenced it's
enough to shut you up
I think perhaps more than anything else
other people were silenced by saying
well you better not say anything about
that look what happened to him
[Music]
the cladding that burned on Grenville
tower was made of combustible plastic
filled decorative panels covering a
thick layer of combustible plastic foam
insulation together they're thought to
have contained as much fuel as 30,000
litres of petrol the stages of a very
big exciting industry they were fitted
to comply with rules brought in by a
government desperate to meet its climate
change commitments in 2011 the
Department for Energy and Climate Change
turned to the insulation industry for
help they set up a committee to cut the
amount of energy wasted by poorly
insulated homes Simon hey now a fire
safety investigator was on the committee
with senior figures from many of the big
insulation firms the point from the
insulation companies is that they were
going to sell a lot more insulation four
of the ten firms represented on that
committee were members of a powerful
plastic insulation lobby group called
brough melida member of the committee
was Rob Warren technical director at
Celotex the firm whose insulation would
be fitted to the outside of Grenville
tower four years later his take on the
committee was revealed on a now-deleted
web page under the heading Celotex enter
government he said he was working inside
government to shape this critical policy
enabling the insulation industry to
maximize the benefits his attitude
reflected the aims of Brookner which
since the Grenville tower fire has
changed its name to the insulation
manufacturers association it states it
has high-level involvement in the
drafting and regular revision of british
and european standards and building
regulations
but according to Simon hey one topic was
not raised in the Whitehall meetings was
fire and safety mentioned in your
hearing no I can't be categorical
because of course the meetings there
were many meetings which took place and
there were a number of years ago but
from my recollection I'm not aware of
the fact that fara was mentioned three
years after getting inside government
Celotex took to the road the building
regulations had been rewritten to make
more insulation compulsory for new
buildings since the plastics industry
sat round the table with civil servants
in 2011 the UK market for plastic
insulation has doubled last year four
million cubic meters of plastic
insulation were fitted to UK buildings
enough to fill Wembley Stadium and all
of it can burn but the industry stresses
how safe it is this video is from the
website of a foam insulation
manufacturer keen to show customers how
it doesn't burn at least not when a
blowtorch is aimed but it's foil
covering to highlight the problem with
plastic insulation which is all made
from oil we took the same product to a
fire laboratory and exposed the
uncovered foam to the radiant heat you'd
get in a real fire it burst into flames
in seconds as the use of plastic grew
the system of regulation was weakened
and how sensible was that I think it was
extremely stupid architect Dion Lombard
says the fetcher government's creation
of private building control inspectors
to compete with local authorities was
the first mistake as soon as you
privatize something like that I mean we
are dealing with human lives at the end
of the day Public Safety which Building
Control is actually essentially
responsible for public safety when you
privatize that you're putting it out in
the market you
putting firms against one are competing
against one another
of course they going to try and make a
profit in 1999 the warning bells began
ringing plastic cladding on Garnica
caught flats in Asia caught fire a man
died and five people were injured MP
Brian Donahoe fought for a parliamentary
inquiry and combustible cladding on
tower blocks in Scotland was banned but
in England no change that's for the
English people to answer the patient I
certainly tried and they didn't want to
listen
tenants in England and Wales got
different standards as the Labour
government turned to its official
advisors samples of gases taken at a
nose height inside the rig show the
death would have been very Swift the
National Building Research Establishment
had been privatized three years earlier
and renamed bre now it had to pay its
way be Ari's answer to the danger from
plastics was to create a fire test for
cladding systems they would use the
building regulations to manage the risk
and get the plastics industry to pay
they called it British standard eight
four one four and then the fire safety
system was weakened further fire
certificates were scrapped before the
regulatory reform order in 2005
buildings had to have a certificate from
a fire officer as an inspection at the
end of a project generally a system of
self certification by building owners is
weaker than a system of certification by
a fire officer somebody whose interest
is directly to make sure his men and
women of fire officers don't die in
fighting a fire but there are holes in
the regulatory reform order that
don't necessarily include the outside of
the block of flats which is in 2009 with
no fire certificates and market
pressures in Building Control plastic
insulation burned on la canal house in
London six people died and 20 were
injured an inquiry by the London
Assembly was told by the Fire Protection
Association that building regulations
have not kept pace with innovation and
lag behind current trends the government
they warned should act immediately the
regulations were not changed there is
insulation available that doesn't burn
it's made from minerals this is fiber
spun from molten rock any fuel to a fire
it does not emit toxic smoke and it will
help suppress a fire because a fire
needs heat one of the key properties of
the fire is it needs heat to keep on
growing and this will suppress the heat
within that building but advertising
that fact has not always proved easy the
plastic insulation industry is highly
litigious senior figures in the cladding
and insulation industry
I told us privately that they are
constantly fearful of legal action from
the plastic insulation industry when
Rockwall launched a marketing campaign
ten years ago to say that this product
was more fire safe than plastic
insulation they were sued for trademark
infringement and malicious the legal
action tied up rockwool for years and
cost them millions of pounds they still
won't talk about it a former government
scientist told me threats left him
worried he lose everything after he
raised concerns he's still too
frightened to be identified his words
are spoken by someone else having been
at the middle of all of this at one time
it did affect my health it was done very
carefully it was a threat to sue it's
enough to shut you up well it is because
if you've got no insurance you lose your
house it was a worrying time and they
were quite famous for it people knew
that this was the way they reacted
I think perhaps more than anything else
other people were silenced by saying
well you better not say anything about
that look what happened to him even the
week after the Grenville tower disaster
the plastics industry was active a paper
from this laboratory on the toxic smoke
given off by plastic insulation provoked
a letter from six plastic industry lobby
groups warning its publishers of
financial consequences obviously it's
quite stressful as well because you
would have to all the complaints or all
the attacks are taken very seriously by
my university it worries me at some
point that if you've got complaints
coming in on annual basis at some point
University will come up and just say how
long we have to handle that while
experts worried about being sued the
fire safety regulations were not working
it would prove to be a dangerous
combination
the deaths of 71 people in the Grenville
tower fire which was fueled by plastic
insulation on the outside covered with
plastic filled cladding prompted a
shocked response from the government MPs
were told the failure of building
regulations and control was a surprise
until the Grenfell fire many experts
would have claimed that that system had
served as well but now we have witnessed
a catastrophic failure on a scale many
thought impossible in 21st century
Britain but the Sky News has established
that the government department in charge
of building regulations had been warned
for years that the system was
dangerously broken
responsibility for the building
regulations lies here with DC LG the
Department for Communities and Local
Government after the la canal house fire
they held a consultation on how the fire
safety rules needed to change they
received 54 submissions but when we
asked to see them they refused
we found one anyway written by insurance
industry trade groups for years before
Grenville tower was refurbished it
pulled no punches urgent research is
required it said into whether the
building regulations are fit for purpose
building regulation enforcement is not
effective with inspectors turning up
less frequently if at all the government
they warned should act to review the
regulations one of the signatories of
that letter was the fire protection
association do you know for certain that
your submission containing warnings
wasn't the only submission containing
warnings yes I've seen other people's
submissions and they also said something
needs to be done urgently absolutely we
are going to be taking on the enemies of
enterprise the bureaucrat but the
warnings weren't heeded and the
coalition government was on a mission to
cut red tape instead of acting on the
warnings the government relied on the
advice of its fire safety advisors BRE
David Cameron was shown plastic
insulation by B Ari's chief executive
Peter bond field by now the market BRE
had created for fire testing cladding
systems had become lucrative
but it won't say how many fire tests the
plastics industry has paid it to carry
out on cladding and insulation or how
much each one costs and it won't say how
many of them failed and had to be
retested until they passed but one of BR
E's biggest clients told us they pay up
to 20,000 pounds per test and that BRE
is paid for dozens of them a year with a
waiting list month long but insurers
think they might have identified a
serious problem they're calling into
question the test itself it is this
really stiff fire but it's gently
burning in reality we don't see that in
modern in modern construction anymore we
will see far more plastics using in a
built environment and it's likely that
the fire when it hits the external it's
the external cladding is going to be of
much different characteristic than
that's slowly burning wood crib a new
fire test is being designed more like a
real building and with a fiercer fire it
will test plastic insulation and mineral
panels declared safe by BRE after the
Grenville tower fire we expect to see
quite different results you expect to
see it effectively failed yeah as
preparations were being made for the
refurbishment of Grenville tower BRE as
fire tests were under pressure the
industry wanted to use more plastics in
2014 to speed things up a new method of
approval was created the trade body for
private building inspectors BCA
said if no actual fire test data exists
for a cladding system opinion would be
good enough they were called desktop
studies and soon they littered sales
brochures mistakes began to creep in it
is not the responsibility of the
architect to question the scientific
basis we are given for the makeup of
materials and the
performance a lot there's a lot of
grayness in talking about materials in
terms of their fire safety by now the
building regulation and control system
that is supposed to keep us safe from
fire was wide open he's kind of creating
a house of cards I'm assessing that
that's okay this document says that's
okay so and other people say well that's
Authority and this Authority say that's
okay so I can say it's okay as the work
on Grenville tower was being completed
bre
in the face of so many widespread
concerns was paid by d CLG to tell them
if tower blocks were safe in a report
dated april 2016 bre said there is
currently no evidence to suggest that
current recommendations are failing in
their purpose the regulations they
assured ministers were adequate we're at
the scene of a major fire in a tower
block a tower block which has been
engulfed in flames within 18 months 71
people were dead the government's
shocked response was to turn to bre
again ministers appointed two of BR ease
senior figures chief executive Peter
bond field and director Sir Ken Knight
to a committee of four to tell them what
to do the owners of high-rise buildings
were told to send cladding panels in for
tests which showed that building
regulations and their enforcement had
failed bre declared that every one of
the two hundred and seventy eight
buildings tested were covered in too
much plastic that burns
as plastic materials came down from
buildings across the country the
shortcomings of B Ari's advice to
ministers was exposed in total hundreds
of buildings had cladding that was
unsafe from Grenville Tower to these
council flats in sulfur and it all goes
back to that decision taken years ago to
try to use the building regulations to
manage the risk of combustible plastic
fitted to high-rise buildings these
flats in sulfur had plastic foam
insulation and exactly the same plastic
filled cladding panels fitted to
Grenville Tower and the whole system
here was signed off by sulfur councils
semi privatized building inspectors it's
now costing millions of pounds to make
these flats safe with extra foil tape
applied to the plastic insulation and
cement based panels fitted to the
outside but any plastic foam insulation
is only as fireproof as the materials
used to keep heat and flames away if
fire can get to the plastic now built
into millions of homes schools hospitals
offices and factories it can burn 12
years ago we had a much different way of
building in the United Kingdom mostly
with non combustible cereals of stone
and masonry we weren't seeing
combustible insulation we weren't seeing
the the wooden construction that we see
these days and a big question mark
actually about whether the regulations
were really fit and appropriate for use
they really needed a fundamental review
the green agenda to insulate homes took
priority over fire safety and experts
warning that lives were at risk have
been made wary of speaking out every
single time that you're getting a
comment right many times hot though or
complain it's always hate you because
you're just thinking what is it now with
privatization introducing market
pressures into fire safety regulation
and control architects developers and
construction come
put combustible material on high-rise
buildings that should never have been
there
you could choose not to use a
combustible cladding material even
though it's not through a loophole in
the regulation is a decision by
designers and connecting contractors it
all led to the tragedy of Grenville
Tower Sky News has identified buildings
across the country covered in
combustible plastics but the owners have
told us that with fire alarms sprinklers
and escape routes their buildings are
not the same as Grenville do you
describe this as a crisis for the UK I
think I would describe this as a crisis
I think fire safety is absolutely vital
and it's not just about the premises
that catch fire it's also about the fact
that people should be able to live
within dwellings with a reasonable
knowledge that they are safe I'm afraid
there will be buildings that are that
are unsafe and and and that must be a
worry for the people who are falling
asleep in them BRE told us it works with
multiple partners across various sectors
including government the emergency
services and the private sector it said
it's working to improve the built
environment through research and the
provision of testing and certification
services which are audited by the UK's
national accreditation body Celotex said
because issues fall within the remit of
the Grenville terror inquiry it is
unable to provide any further
information but is offering full
cooperation with the ongoing
investigations adi CLG spokesperson said
nothing is more important than keeping
people safe
after the coroner's investigation into
the la canal house fire in 2013
government took action to implement all
the recommendations we are continuing to
work on updating our fire safety
guidance and the insulation
manufacturers association formerly known
as brough mer says it feeds into any
building regulation reviews through all
the you
xual public channels and denies it or
its members have used legal action to
silence critics
Grenville tower remains a crime scene
the Metropolitan Police says there are
reasonable grounds to suspect offences
of corporate manslaughter Sir Martin
Moore big has promised his public
inquiry will get at the truth of what
caused the disaster and Dame Judith
Hackett is conducting a review of
building regulations and fire safety but
it is far from clear whether anyone is
asking why with so little debate so much
material that burns is still being added
to Britain's buildings
you